[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter Star
Wars épisode 4 newo pour un nouvel
espoir en français donc c'est le premier
des Star Wars le film originel réalisé
écrit par Georges Lucas est sorti en
1977 il faut savoir que Star Wars c'est
le troisième signe de George Lucas après
son film entre guillemets de fin d'étude
THX en 138 et son premier vrai film
American graffiti et à l'époque non
seulement la science-fiction était un
genre qui était désuet personne ne
croyait dans ce projet c'était pas un
conseil comme des films sérieux c'était
pas conseillé comme des films de cinéma
et George Lucas s'est battu et a pu
grâce au soutien notamment de Alan
ladjunior à la Fox faire ce film mais
voilà il faut savoir que aujourd'hui ça
paraît évident Star Wars mais à l'époque
c'était vraiment personne ne croyait ni
en lui ni dans le projet et personne ne
comprenait ce qui voulait faire
[Musique]
que les films de George Lucas et Star
Wars sont aussi beaucoup inspirés par
les films de Samurai d'Akira Kurosawa
dont il était un grand fan c'est le film
qui m'a donné envie de faire du cinéma
que j'ai vu quand j'étais tout petit et
surtout ce qu'on oublie beaucoup au-delà
de au-delà de Star Wars en tant que tel
on oublie souvent le côté technicien
quelque part de Georges Lucas qui arrive
Sony toute l'industrie derrière la
caméra c'est à dire que sans George
Lucas on n'aurait pas du son numérique
au cinéma aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas de
projection numérique on n'aurait pas les
effets spéciaux tel qu'on les connaît
c'est en grande partie pas que mais en
grande partie grâce à lui grâce à la
création de sa société ILM que
aujourd'hui on a les Marvel on a les
d'ici on a tous ces films avec les
effets spéciaux qu'on connaît parce qu'à
l'époque ça coulait pas de source et
c'était un des un des pionniers à la
fois continuer à faire beaucoup de
maquettes
et de marionnettes à l'ancienne et aussi
à pousser les effets numériques
notamment la séquence du briefing ou la
princesse Leïa et le général montrent
les plans les toits noirs c'est de la
première séquence entièrement générée
par ordinateur du sort du cinéma c'est
le film pour s'évader c'est le film qui
nous fait voyager c'est le film qui nous
montre que une galaxie autour de nous et
plein de belles choses à voir et ça fait
surtout qui donne de l'espoir
[Musique]